il faut bien vivre avec une maladie
psychique c'est le thème du concours
vidéo de l'association art convergence
basée dans les yvelines troisième
édition de ce prix vidéo ouvert à tous
dont l'appel à projets a été lancé le
principe produire une vidéo de quatre
minutes maximum documentaires reportages
fictions ou encore film d'animation qui
évoque la maladie psychique
l'objectif est que les participants
s'approprie le sujet et l'intègre un
processus créatif et les vidéos seront
départagés par un jury et varié composé
notamment de professionnels médical et
de l'audiovisuel
un grand prix un prix du jury ou un
autre du public seront remis notamment
avec des dotations allant jusqu'à 5000
euros laurence du pain et la présidente
d'art convergence c'est pas une campagne
sans savoir que l'association avait été
créée pour aider directement à travers
les croisés artistique qualitatif des
débats on a commencé par parler des
petits groupes de personnes dans les
talents artistiques des envies
artistiques avec des artistes connus et
les vertes par les scouts de sucre et on
a eu des idées on a eu une vidéo et qui
a été un des kills parce que c'était un
très compromis cette vidéo a été
extraordinaire il ya les vieux sera
d'abord un guillaume jeux artistiques et
des bons pneus hiver débat forcément
activités de cette dernière la tête
ailleurs on s'est dit que finalement
monté un appel à projets ça permettait
d'élargir le nombre de turbines
concernés d'abord par le la restitution
parce que la vidéo c'est quelque chose
maternelle et très facilement
c'est à la fois beaucoup moins cher à
produire s'il a reculé et les personnes
du parti peuvent bien beaucoup plus
d'eau chaude en attaque c'est écrasant
les participants ont jusqu'au 1er
octobre pour envoyer leur dossier
d'inscription et leurs vidéos